hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
titled zoom ab antibodies a novel
recombinant of antibody technology
this webinar is part of the cancer
research and oncology virtual event
and i'm susie valdez of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by
lab roots and sponsored by millipore
sigma
for more information about millipore
sigma go to www.sigmaaldrich.com
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
at the end of the presentation if you
have any trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen as a reminder
the presentation is educational and
offers free continuing
education credits click on the
continuing education credits tab
located on the top right hand corner of
your presentation window
and follow the process to obtain those
credits i now present today's speaker dr
wayne speckman head of anti-body
development
for complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr speckman welcome you may now begin
your presentation sir
hello this is wayne speckman i'm from
millipore sigma i'm
an r d uh scientist and i'm going to be
presenting a new technology
uh called zoomab today uh it's a
recombinant
antibody technology
so just a quick agenda so obviously i'm
just going to spend a little time
talking about antibodies
make sure we're all on the same page
i'll dive into zuma and what exactly
these recombinant antibodies are and how
they work
and how they're developed i'll kind of
then
shift into talking about our entire
portfolio of antibodies
and then finally finish off with some
resources
so antibody overview so as many of you
are probably aware antibodies have
become an important research tool for
scientists
um you know researchers including
clinicians
you know use them to identify and
isolate specific molecules so the
antibodies are very specific
um targeting a very particular molecule
typically so
they're used for identification of
target molecules they're identification
they're utilized for local location of
target molecules
you know often these target molecules
are markers for a cell type or even a
tissue type
they can be markers for disease or
physiological states
and then sometimes antibodies can even
be used for purification um or
concentrating a particular target so
there's a lot of functionality and uses
for antibodies
antibodies are kind of broadly broken up
into two two types
polyclonal and monoclonal so polyclonals
shown on the top are a mixture of many
different antibodies
these antibodies are non-identical
because there are many different
b cells that are producing each each
antibody so each different type of
antibody is produced by a different
specific b cell
and so they detect multiple targets and
epitopes
okay in contrast there's um the
monoclonals which is just
one single type of antibody so they're
all the exact same
sequence of amino acids and they're
identical because they're all produced
from
one um b cell or a clone from a single
parent
cell a beast of b cells
um so they're all exactly the same and
obviously they
the difference is they're going to be
detecting one hopefully one epitope
um and they all will the specificity
would be this
is produced from those be a particular b
cell
so there's advantages and disadvantages
um and so we're going to
go into some of the um some of these for
polys and monos so polyclonals you know
they're easy to generate
um very cost effective uh
you know you simply uh immunize an
animal with immunogen
and pull out the the serum and you're
going to have a polyclonal mixture
there's going to be lots of antibodies
in that mixture um hopefully most of
them for the particular target of
interest but
that animal also is going to have
antibodies to anything that it's been
exposed to
the polyclonals might have multiple
epitopes on the same protein so a one
protein
might be targeted by numerous antibodies
and sometimes this is good because it
can lead to more robust
signals in some immunoassays
this sometimes is is helpful
especially with proteins expressed in
low levels to get a stronger signal
in testing polyclonals are often
compatible with a broader range of
applications
and sometimes there's higher flexibility
and antigen recognition because of
being able to recognize multiple uh
epitopes
in contrast monoclonals um
you know different clones of antibodies
can be generated to different epitopes
so
you know you can have different
antibodies that only recognize a
particular epitope because the clone
that was selected
only that antibody is selected because
it only detects one epitope
um the hybridoma serves as an infinite
source of the same antibody
so once that hybridoma is produced and
identified and isolated
uh it's it's kind of an infinite source
uh
if it's screened properly there can be
minimal background and cross reactivity
so that the antibody is
that selected from a hybridoma is very
clean
you know that is certainly helpful for
monoclonals and tends to be a bonus
that's different from polyclonals and
because they're
uh producing only that one antibody you
get high homogeneity
consistent and reproducible results
and then there's less batch to batch
variation because it's all
produced by one clone so
some of the the challenges for
polyclonals obviously
the animals have a certain lifespan and
that limits the amount
of polyclonal material that can be
produced
if the animal dies prematurely that can
also lead to
less material so there's definitely a
lifespan and a limited
amount that that's produced uh
the other thing is over time as the
animal is exposed
and re-exposed due through boost uh the
bleeds that are produced
may give different results the animal
may have a lower titer
giving thus thus less signal or it may
even completely change and lose the
ability to
to produce antibody against the target
of interest so
bleeds over time with one organism may
change
this obviously causes greater batch to
batch variability
you might get non-specific antibodies
again because this is polyclonal
you can have antibodies that are
recognizing multiple different targets
and this can lead to
background signal
and immunization of a new animal with
the same antigen
may lead to different epitopes so even
if that original material that was great
was produced when you try to make it
again there's no guarantee
that the the that additional organisms
that are immunized with the
the exact same immunogen are going to
produce the exact same antibodies again
they're they're polyclonal they're
different
so there's no idea there's no guarantee
that you'll get the same
and then there's their shared epitopes
on different proteins
so you might get background because the
epitope that's recognized with one
is also recognized on a second protein
so some challenges for monoclonals um
sometimes limited working applications
so some some monoclonals just only work
in a particular application or two
and that's obviously got to be tested to
be verified but
that can be an issue they are
susceptible to loss of epitope because
it's only recognizing one epitope if
that epitope gets
gets modified or changed or affected
you may lose the actual detection in a
test
uh sometimes there's higher specificity
limits
uh with multiple species uh one of the
big issues that that
that is that can occur with with
monoclonals is hybridoma cell line drift
which means over time either the
expression changes or the sequence
changes and the
the cell line itself which is assumed to
be exactly the same from the very
beginning to
months and years later may not be
exactly the same
and then obviously contamination or loss
of the cell line would be a huge issue
um if if there's contamination and
the cells are dead there is no bringing
that back you'd have to completely
restart it or
at least hope that you had other um
vials of of of cells that are somewhere
else stored somewhere else that are that
are still okay
so one of the great things is that sort
of the best of both worlds is to
actually use recombinant monoclonal
antibodies
and that's what zoomabs are and we'll
get into that in more detail but
recombinant
antibodies are manufactured by cloning
antibody genes into expression vector
vectors which are subsequently
introduced into expression systems to
provide
animal free and even preservative free
antibody production so there's a lot of
benefits
uh no antibody sequence mutations uh
high batch to batch consistency at the
same exact
process is used in terms of making them
and purifying the
the recombinant antibodies significantly
reduce production time
you don't have to wait for an animal you
don't you literally are doing it in
culture so it's very quickly
in terms of the turnaround time there is
increased rep
reproducibility and control because the
the conditions from
from one batch to the next batch are
exactly the same there's
zero or very minimal um
variation so that the reproducibility is
excellent
uh it's easy to develop um humanized or
alternate versions where you mutate some
of the sequence if
if needed uh if there's a poor
expression you can
replace a trna low that's a low quantity
or low
amount with a higher trna to get better
expression
as i mentioned before it's animal-free
technology so once the antibody sequence
is obtained
you never have to go back into an animal
like a poly to try and make it again
and the sequence is known so we we have
the sequence in hand
so even if something happens and we lose
the expression vector we could always
reconstruct it
and that's some great power to have
so zoo maps so let's go into the details
on what what zoo maps are so
again these are recombinant antibodies
this is a new generation
of proprietary recombinant monoclonal
antibodies uh
they're specifically engineered to
combine state-of-the-art consistency
and application performance so i
mentioned it's it's a new technology
we'll go into some of that in here in a
minute
uh improved consistency very efficient
design and packaging so the marketing
team spent a lot of time and effort
um working on those aspects and and
we'll go into some of that detail
there's enhanced validation for all of
these
um and then there's a very robust
pipeline with a lot of zuma still
coming out that have come out and is
well still coming
so the zoo map technology so that you
know this kind of shows you that the
differences between the traditional
and um and how the zoo map is so so on
the left
is the traditional uh process map so you
immunize an animal you isolate the
splenocytes and
these are the be essentially the b cells
and you then have to do a fusion with
hybridoma or cancer cells
to form the the hybridomas the
the cancer cell lines that are used to
then express
the monoclonal antibody
limited species only pretty much only
rabbits and and mice are used
to make these now the difference with
the zuma technology
is we're not pulling the b cells we're
not pulling the splenocytes and having
to sacrifice the animals to do this
we basically start at the b cells by
purifying them from blood so we can just
take blood
from the animal that's been immunized
you pull the blood that has the b cells
and
through a proprietary process those b
cells are
immortalized and we can then do the
screening of
those b cells to identify the
um the ones that are expressing the
antibody um
of interest the antibody that's specific
uh for the target
okay so the screening process there is
kind of similar to how the screening
process with traditional hybridomas
occurs the difference there is that
these are not fused with a cancer cell
so
we take the the b cells and we
manipulate them with the proprietary
process to
to keep them those cells then once we
identify which cells are actually
performing
and and expressing the the antibody of
interest we can take that cell
clone out the uh the antibody sequence
and put it into our proprietary
expression vector
and and then we are producing the
antibodies recombinantly
so you can kind of see on the chart on
the right the the advantages and
disadvantages
kind of in broad terms for each of them
uh
polyclonals being great for species
diversity
targeting difficult targets but the
specificity and reproducibility
are obviously drawbacks mouse uh
traditional monoclonals and even rabbit
monoclonals you know
are not so good with the species uh
diversity and not as
good with the difficult targets but are
obviously good with specificity and
reproducibility but the cost and the
development times are higher
and then the beauty of the zoo maps is
all of them are are very good
and then because we're developing these
the time and the cost to develop them is
on us and not on the researchers so
you know you're able to just step in
right there and and get the antibodies
the zoo maps from us so you don't have
to you're not impacted by the
development cost and time
so zoomab so the the phase one is is
rabbit monoclonals that's
what we're starting with um we're
starting to work on other species we've
we've
launched a number of mouse ones we're
working on llama and goat and other
species as well
and those will be coming shortly but
most of the data that i'll be presenting
today is rabbit
um and so some of the advantages of
using rabbit as the host is
is it elicits a stronger immune response
um
you can use simpler immunogens uh when
compared to mouse
uh you can often get higher affinity
antibodies that are produced by the
rabbit
you know there's more lymphocytes
typically produced
they're easily humanized they're all one
species they're all igg
uh they produce diverse antibodies so
you do get a lot of different
uh antibodies and and you can even
target unusual structures like
phosphopeptides carbohydrates ptm
modifications
they're better suited than than
monoclonals for immunohistochemistry and
flow cytomic
uh applications and produce some high
quality data that i'll show some
examples of
and then finally they recognize epitopes
of human antigens that do not display
immunogenicity in rodents
so the the ana the advantages of rabbits
are are pretty nice and those have been
well documented
so in terms of the zoo map development
process you know i talked about this
briefly but i'll kind of
go into detail so the immortalized b
cells are screened for positive clones
okay so this is the the testing process
to find
which clones and the top clones that are
tested
in multiple immunoassays the best clones
are sequenced then and reverse
engineered into a recombinant expression
system
the zoomab recombinant antibody is then
expressed using animal and serum free
conditions it's affinity purified it's
again tested in multiple immunoassays to
ensure functionality so to ensure that
the
recombinant expressed is matching the
uh antibody that's produced from the b
cell so we do testing
all testing at both stages to verify
the optimal concentration of the
recombinant antibody is determined
and then the zoomab recombinant antibody
is actually lyophilized for long-term
storage and stability
and so it's produced and shipped to
customers it as a lyophilized for in a
lyophilized format
and then of course there is quality
control testing um
to ensure that the the antibody is
functional post literalization so we
actually
reconstitute and verify that every zoo
map that is produced
is functional and that the
lyophilization process did not hinder
or impact the the functionality
so here's an example of one of the zoo
maps that was produced this is a zoo map
targeting
uh new end uh so nuan is a
is a marker uh in brain in neurons
and you can see a variety of tests here
but
western blot nuan is is known to be
produced as two
two a doublet band around 50 kd uh you
could
very clearly see clean western blot data
the antibody works well in ihc so here's
a
mouse brain and hippocampal region
showing showing
lovely staining uh indeed
immunofluorescence
of uh hippocampus as well and with a
closer
image of the the neurons in the in the
cortex region
as well as in immunocytochemistry using
primary neuronal cultures
uh again showing uh the functionality of
the antibody in
multiple different amino acids
here's an example of a zoomab produced
for beta
beta tubulin iii uh again western blot
showing a nice clean band in in mouth or
human brain tissue
uh primary cultures
or excuse me know shsy 5y
uh cell line and neuronal cell culture
cell line
and then as well as in
ihc on mouse cerebral cortex
and you know again lovely staining
lovely
results in three different immunoassays
each
uh zoomab is is validated in a minimum
of three different
amino acids and here's a third example
a gfap this is an astrocytic marker
again showing western blot icc
and ihc and immunofluorescence so this
one even has four
validations shown and this is kind of
typical of the data that's going to be
seen
um for any of the the zoomab targets
here's an example of a ptm so a
post-translational modification so this
this
zoomab targets the anti-phospho histone
h2ax serine 139 a classic marker
and um you can see in the first
western blot this is minus and plus
stimulation so you clearly see the
the the detection of the phosphorylation
the the second image is a peptide
inhibition assay
so it's um a western blot where you then
do no incubation with the peptide
incubation the second lane is the
peptide without the phosphorylation
group
which doesn't inhibit or block the
western blot signal
and then the third lane is um
the pre-incubation with the peptide that
contains the phospho at the serine 139
residue and you can see that the
um the antibody is completely blocked
from functioning then so the
uh that this shows that the specificity
of the antibody for the phosphorylation
site
and then it's also been is tested in ihc
uh in testes as well as
immunocytochemistry
um with hela cells that are treated with
or without sterosporine to induce the
the phosphorylation uh of histone h2ax
and its nuclear signal that you clearly
see in the
image on the far right so again
zoom apps can be created for ptms
and then here's one of the the mouse uh
zoomabs that we've just launched as well
uh anti-nestin and you know again
validated in western blot on the left uh
in icc
and shsy 5y cells in the center as well
as in ihc on human kidney
staining glomeruli on the left and the
negative control
knowing no staining as expected so again
lots of different applications
every antibody is tested in numerous um
applications in the
um on our website you'll find
information on every target that's
produced and it'll typically look
something like this giving
background information the specificity
details about the immunogen the
applications that it was tested on and
past
testing on as well as just a general
general description
of the target so this is commonly found
on each either a c of a
or on the website for every zoo map
so again zoomabs recombinant antibodies
the recombinant expression
gives excellent reproducibility i
mentioned its serum pre-production
there's multiple uh validations and
characterizations
including i didn't show it but but many
of them have been tested by knockout
data as well uh affinity purified for
highest reproducibility and performance
excellent affinity avidity and
specificity
i did mention the at least three
different immunoassays
they do have high thermostability and
longer shelf life in the
the lyophilized form and i'll show some
of that data here in a second
uh and so far we've launched over 200
zoom abs
and we have over a thousand in
development uh and in fact i can mention
the covid
zoom abs actually just launched so if
anyone's doing covid
uh 19 studies they would be able to use
some of the zoom apps that we've
produced for that
so i mentioned the the the
lyophilization
um so the zoomabs are produced and and
are lyophilized
and this data here shows that how how
how the lyophilization affects
functionality and you can see
lanes one and two on the left is a
western blot of
one of the targets so this was new n on
the left
uh lane one is the unlyophilized
and lane two is after lyophilization and
then resuspension
and you basically see no difference in
the in the intensity of the western blot
data
the the second set of of
western blot lanes there is for nmdar
dar-2a again showing
one lane one is not lyophilized
and lane two is post lyophilization and
resuspension
and again you see almost no difference
and then on the right hand side
is some ihc and icc staining of sox9
another zoomab and again
on the left are images of
of samples not lyophilized and on the
right is
post-levelization and then re-suspended
and you can basically see there's
essentially no difference
and all of both of those were tested
so very consistent before and after
lyophilization
okay and part of the reason we wanted to
go to this lyophilization is just
our commitment to green initiatives i
mean the beauty of having antibodies
these zoom abs
blafflies it eliminates the use of of
any kind of polystyrene coolers and ice
bricks and the shipping containers
and the weight that is that is required
or that is
the package weight when when one of
these antibodies is shipped to you
customer is dramatically reduced
um and then all the zoomabs
uh you know i've mentioned this but
they're all are biocide
preservative and animal free so pure
product
minimizes complications arising
potentially hazardous materials
you know local safety restrictions
things like
um sodium azide restrictions in certain
locations
it's not even in the vial so it's not a
concern at all
and the recombinant platform minimizes
animal involvement and production
processes so there's a lot of benefits
to to utilizing and
shipping the products to you in this
manner
um in terms of the vials themselves when
they show up so the
the uh lyophilized product you know
will be located down obviously at the
bottom of the tube the
the the blue little marker but there a
lot of thought was put into the design
in the production and the packaging of
these vials by the the marketing teams
um you know you you know targeting
trying to generate a new generation of
antibodies with superior specificity
the lot to lock consistency thinking
about sustainability
shipping ambiently for the environment
to reduce shipping costs
uh obviously very stable uh pure
the vials are this are transparent so
you're able to see that that lyophilized
pellet in the tube very
clearly um so the vials and the labels
are clear and transparent
and then and then a nice thing is
they're actually
freestanding vials so you can actually
have it standing up or
it fits in a standard brack versus most
lyophilized samples
do not so this is very nice for the
customer
so this is typically what the the vials
look like here there's an example of a
label
the anti-nesting uh zumab
um you know we talk i mentioned the
concentrations most of them are at
either
330 microgram per mil or 300 microgram
per mill after reconstruct
reconstitution at 25 microliters
um we we in our r d
testing determine the amount um that
that it's required
and works for the customer so that you
get the proper amount so you can just go
and actually know okay it should work at
one to one thousand in western blotting
and one to one hundred in icc or ihc
so it really takes the the onus off the
customer you just resuspend it
and then you go and you go straight into
testing but this is
typically the kind of information that
you'll find on the on the
on the website and or on the label
so just a few couple slides on the the
overall
antibody portfolio we have nearly a
hundred thousand antibodies
obviously they're highly cited highly
characterized many are award-winning
we have extensive expertise in this area
with over 35 years of experience
developing manufacturing characterizing
testing
and supporting antibody products so
you know a lot of expertise in this area
uh to help you out if you have questions
cust
or concerns so our antibody portfolio is
very diverse
you know there's we obviously have an
extensive line of primary antibodies we
offer a little
extensive number of secondary antibodies
we offer the highly characterized
prestige antibodies
many of our antibodies are top sided um
we're now offering small pack sizes for
many of the antibodies so if you just
want to test a small
small amount of antibody there's that
available for many of them now and
a lot of them are going to be offered in
that format eventually
and obviously enhanced validation is a
is a key
and we're trying to note that on our
website which antibodies have have
enhanced validation
so in summary our competitive edge you
know what we offer
with with zoom ads so you know affinity
purified for highest
reproducibility and performance
excellent binding
affinity avidity and specificity
multiple application validation and
characteristic
characterization analyzed in at least
three different
amino acid applications low bio burden
development
and manufacturing process they're highly
stable in the lyophilized format
they can be shipped at ambient
temperature the
zoo maps are preservative free so you
can can use them for
cell-based applications or functional
assays
they're offered in multiples of 25
microliters so you never have to buy
more than what you need
there's they're highly thermostable with
longer shelf life
in the lyophilized format and we've even
got qr codes that are on these
antibodies so you can
use your phone and even just click to
link to
the uh the zoo map website to get
information on any antibody without
having to go to a
a lab to a computer in the lab if you
need information
on one of the antibodies
so some of the resources um that are
available so so
sigmaaldrich.com backslash zoomab is the
site you'll want to go to
um you'll that's that'll get you to a
landing page that's sort of the hub for
all the zoomab information
there's brochures there there's further
articles
technical articles um and and
examples of numerous antibodies
obviously the listing of all of the zoo
maps that we've launched thus far
are located there there's a frequently
asked questions flyer that'll
that has numerous questions on it that
anything that you may have
thought of um and you know
uh again if you have further questions
there's links there that you can contact
tech support to get even more
information or to
touch base in terms of which zoo maps
are coming out
and any of the new launches as they come
out they're coming out
essentially on a monthly monthly basis
uh those would actually get posted here
um
and i believe there's also links to get
on a mailing list there so that you
could actually get that information in
real time as soon as they become
available
so again zoom abs are prominent
antibody technology and
i thank you for your time
thank you dr speckman for that
informative presentation
we will now start the q a portion of our
webinar
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen so let's get started
we already have some great questions
coming in
dr speckman what a menu um
video assay application do you use
for each of the zoom ab antibodies
yes so for the zoomabs it it's target
dependent so
it depends on what the the actual target
is that we're we're designing a zoom app
for
so um it's going to vary as i mentioned
you know we do at least three for each
of them
but it's going to depend on you know
like if it's a
neuro target we're going to do typically
try and get validation for ihc because
we know that that's the the the
immunoassay that most people are going
to use whereas if it's a
a cytokine we're gonna we're gonna do
flow if it's
you know it's so just it's target
dependent if it's a you know an antibody
that we know is gonna be used for
um epigenetics you know we would almost
certainly try and do chip assays on that
one and validate it in ip or chip
um so it's it's pretty much dependent
but again we we show all the data so
you'll be able to see all of that
and it's it is three applications that
we target
thank you so much and how do you
resuspend
the lifelized pellets
okay so so it's it's pretty simple you
can you simply just
you know open up the tube and you add 25
microliters of
buffer pbs buffer or water to the tube
um and you just then mix the tube gently
for a few minutes five or ten minutes
and
and then you're ready to go and it's
it's ready to roll
thank you so much and i want to thank
our audience members for these great
questions coming in
our next audience members asks i'm
curious
how are the zoom ab antibodies different
or why would you recommend it versus
other recombinant
um rabbit monocolonal
monoclonal antibodies that might be
currently being used
well it's hard for me to say what what
what the other um
how the other recombinant antibodies are
made i i can only speak to our
recombinant antibodies i know how our
antibodies are made i know that we do
extensive screening to validate them to
make sure that they're actually
specific for the target that the the
non-specific binding is minimal or
non-existent
uh that they were extensively validated
in numerous applications you know that
that there
is no um preservative
in them that they were made animal free
so really
you know it is just an antibody
okay so other companies make antibodies
but again it's it's all of the
the prep work that goes into making that
antibody and doing the testing on it to
show that it's actually specific
um is the difference thank you so much
dr speckman
now how many species does the zoom ab
offer
so currently we we do we only offer two
at the moment um rabbit and mouse but we
are as i mentioned we are working on
others we we've been doing internal
testing
of of goat
of guinea pig of sheep some others llama
so you know we're just not ready to roll
those out yet we want to perfect it
before we
launch those but that's kind of why it's
called zoo map is because eventually we
will have
additional um antibodies against
different species
and it in a in a in theory it should
work on most
any species that we want so that's
that's kind of why the zoomab
moniker is used thank you so much and we
have time for a couple
of more questions from our audience
members
our next one how stable is the zoom ab
antibody after you resuspend it
okay sure so yeah once it's resuspended
it's it's
pretty much like a typical antibody um
i believe our um storage
recommendations are one year um from
that point
you know we i would recommend that you
probably handle it like you would a
normal antibody if you're going to use
it within a short amount of time
you know four degrees storage is fine if
it's going to be longer than that
uh i would probably make aliquots and
freeze
freeze different aliquots just to to
keep longer storage term
time thank you so much
and dr speckman we have time for one
more question
our audience member wants to know can i
use the zoom
ab antibodies with other antibodies that
i have
yeah absolutely so you know again it's
it's
whether it's a rabbit or a mouse
obviously most of the ones that we've
launched so far are rabbit there are
a number of mouse ones that have come
out it would be no different
than using any other rabbit antibody
that you have with another
with another antibody and doing
multiplexing experiments
um you know again you would still have
to test to determine whether or not
there's cross reactivity with the
antibodies
but yeah it shouldn't be any different
than any of the those other kind of
applications
um you know again the beauty of these is
that they're monoclonal
there should be limited cross reactivity
um
so you know but but yeah they should
work just fine
you know again you would have to test
that empirically though
dr speckman thank you again today for
your presentation
and for your time and for clearly your
important research
and before we go i want to thank our
audience members for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
i'd also like to thank our sponsor mila
por sigma for sponsoring today's webinar
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information
you provided at the time of your
registration and this webcast
can be viewed on demand for six months
until april 2021
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time take care stay healthy
and take care for now bye-bye